Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
yeah, we're back at the
round table of dim lighting.
Yep.
We're gonna be talking about
what really happened at MythiCon.
Yeah, this is-
As if there's a secret that
we've been holding onto.
There's not really.
Well, I think there's-
It's just a sensational introduction.
I mean, there's definitely
some behind the scenes.
Oh yeah.
Like, I mean, there's things
that we haven't talked about,
about our experience that, you know,
I think it's good to just put it down,
put down our experience,
to tape or whatever type
of digital ones and zeros
we record things to, for posterity.
Yeah, because it's very fresh right now.
So fresh.
We just got back home,
just a couple of days ago.
The wounds are still open.
So the experience is very,
very fresh on our minds
and in our hearts.
I would say that the
general feeling right now,
both the general feeling
while we were at MythiCon,
and then as MythiCon was coming to a close
and in these days after,
is that it was a success.
Like, we're feeling really good
about the way that the Mythical
Beasts responded to it,
the work that the
Mythical crew put into it.
I mean, the thing that we said all along
is that if we can create
a positive experience
for the majority of people who were there,
then we have succeeded.
Because when you go out
and try to do something
for the first time,
that hasn't been done before...
A convention? Especially.
... at least by us.
Yeah.
And, you know, something
like this specifically
hasn't been done in creatordom.
This sort of more boutique event
or whatever you want to call it,
at a place that wasn't
a convention center.
Boutique immersive two day experience.
We're feeling good.
I'm feeling good.
That doesn't mean that there
weren't things that went wrong
and there weren't things that
could have been done better
and there's not constructive
criticism floating around,
which we can talk a little bit about.
But yeah, I mean, my first thing was
nobody died, was maimed, or
taken away on a stretcher.
Honestly, yeah.
So, I was just so glad because,
like, these conventions
have a reputation for, like,
really going south, you know.
There's documentaries made about them.
Well, as the days approached, I mean,
that is one of the things
I wanted to talk about,
was just the way that we
were feeling about things
as the date was approaching.
Right, and I'll say,
I also wanna talk about,
like, we will talk about
what does this this mean
for the future of MythiCon?
What are our plans?
What do we know?
We know some things already,
so we can talk about that.
Yep.
So yeah, so you can go
back to your feelings now.
I will say, ultimately, before
we start stepping through it,
I kind of feel like I'm
basking in the afterglow
of a milestone career moment.
Like, just being able
to experience MythiCon
was extremely positive for me personally.
And I'm just so grateful that
we have a relationship
with the Mythical Beasts,
such that, like, we can all get excited
about creating something like this.
And it was really special.
Like, there were a number
of points where I was like,
I think this is the peak for me.
This is my favorite thing about MythiCon.
And that happened probably five times.
Well, the way I described it on Twitter,
I guess on Sunday, you know, or Monday,
right after it was over,
it represented a culmination
of this relationship
that we've been building for many years.
I think that that is,
that's why I'm taking away,
despite some of the things
that were like lessons learned,
that we will take into the future,
which we were fully expecting, it's like,
you do something for the first time,
you're like, oh, this, this and that,
these are things that we would change,
these are things that
we would do differently.
You go into a new venture
expecting to learn those lessons.
But the thing that I was really hoping
would be the core experience of the event
would be that this relationship
that we've been building
with the Mythical Beasts,
and for some, that's a
over 10 year relationship.
For some, that's a 10 week relationship
and everything in between.
That it would feel-
Some are like 16 years.
That the relationship
that had been building
and had been cultivated
was being expressed,
almost in the way that if you think about
you've got somebody, you
have a long distance,
and I don't wanna make this,
it's not like a romantic thing,
but a friendship, let's just say.
You meet somebody.
A pen pal.
And actually this is the
case with a lot of people
that we ended up talking
to in the meet and greet
and then in the brunch,
we got to interact a total of eight hours
over the course of two
days, two and a half days.
We ended up having,
I don't know if you
thought about it like this,
eight hours of direct
interaction with Mythical Beasts.
Like one on one, one on two, one on three.
Oh wow.
When you count your
James and the Shame set?
No, no, I'm counting-
No, if you count James and
the Shame and your DJ set.
For you and then my DJ set.
And then I'm talking, that's 10 hours.
I'm saying-
Yeah.
A two hour meet and greet on Friday,
a two hour meet and greet on Saturday
and then a four hour brunch on Sunday.
I don't know if you realized,
we were there from 10
o'clock to two o'clock,
interacting with people individually,
going around going around to each table.
Like it was a wedding reception.
Yeah.
And in one sense, it
was emotionally draining
because to have, sometimes,
intense interactions
with people who are, you know,
they've got a lot of things
that they've been feeling
and thinking for years
that now they have an
opportunity to tell you.
But for the most part,
including those things,
it was ultimately very energizing.
I agree, yeah.
It's like you've got this pen pal
that you've been talking to for years.
Who never writes you back,
but you know they're reading all of them.
Yeah.
And they might post things publicly.
And then the relationship
is kinda consummated.
Don't do it.
In person.
And that's the funny thing
is we kept seeing people who
are like, yeah I've been,
this is a Mythical Beast
that I have a friendship with
and now we've been
hanging out all weekend.
There's that that was
happening, which was beautiful
and which was why we
wanted to do it in person
and bring people together.
But then there were the
interactions that we could have,
and not just with us,
everybody got to interact with the crew
both in a meet and greet setting,
but also just because
it was this little town.
And I think that that was
the peak of it for me,
was seeing that this relationship that has
been building for so long
can kind of be expressed in a way
that you can only do in person.
And, yeah, when you describe it as, like,
a boutique immersive experience,
that was what was so
exciting to see come together
because that was part
of our original idea.
You know, it could have
been two years ago, right?
When we first hatched
the idea of MythiCon,
in the throes of the
pandemic and lockdown,
in our opening speech
from the rooftop where,
man, I could have fallen off that roof.
Yeah.
Well the one instruction
that was given to Link,
and there's gonna be a number of things
like this that come up, I'm sure.
But the one instruction
that was given to Link,
at least five times, was when
you step out on this roof,
there will be a rug that's big enough
for the two of you to stand on.
Don't step off of that,
because at that moment
you'll be on just like a tin roof
that may have condensation on it,
it's not, you know, it could be slippery.
And literally the first thing you did
was step off of the rug.
Well I took a step and
then I took a second step
and then I was looking at
all the people down there
and then I looked down at my foot
and I remembered I'm
supposed to stay on the rug.
And when I looked down at my second step,
that foot that was out there,
I was like, there's no rug at all.
Where's the rug?
And I realized, I had
already stepped over the rug.
Yeah, it was the first thing.
It was just-
There's only one step of the rug.
I pictured a rug going from the window
that we stepped out of onto that rooftop,
like, it's like a red carpet
going right to the edge.
Well, that's what you would picture.
And then when I looked down,
I was looking all around for the rug.
Then I looked behind me and saw the rug
and I saw you standing on it.
If you had...
I took a step back.
If you had slipped off and, like,
I had to, like, go out there
and, like, hold you up,
that would've been,
Would've been so awesome.
first of all, everyone would've thought,
no, they wouldn't have
thought that it was planned.
They would've known.
Because the other thing that was planned.
We should have done that.
The other thing that was planned,
a little behind the scenes here,
is that we were also told multiple times,
but unfortunately we weren't
told right before we did it,
that someone was planning a proposal
and that really, our only job was to...
Recognize this guy.
Welcome everybody to MythiCon,
cover some logistics that actually
we didn't even need to cover
because they were covered elsewhere.
And then just throw it over to this guy,
Wesley was his name,
Weatherholtz, Wesley Weatherholtz.
Still is his name.
Great name.
Throw it over to Wesley
Unless he's taken her name.
and then Wesley would take it from there.
He was like in a light, you know,
like, there was a basically, like,
he was under a light so
everybody could see him.
And he was going to propose
He was waiting.
to his girlfriend.
He was waiting
our entire speech.
And our other job, I will say,
was to give a kick-ass welcome speech
after Cotton Candy Randy introduced us.
And I think we delivered man.
Yeah, agreed.
We had one microphone, we had to share it.
We didn't get in a fight.
Almost did.
I didn't go too off the rails.
Yeah.
I didn't weep.
You wore a pink hat.
I found the pink hat,
up there in the attic.
But yeah, he was waiting for our
kick-ass speeches to be done
and you know, just imagine
you're gonna propose,
like, I was so nervous
when I was gonna propose
and I did it two weeks early by accident.
You know, this guy was
like, I'm about to do it.
All they gotta do is say my name
and then we go through the whole speech
and then we're like wrapping things up
and then we like say, "Tata for now",
and we go back in and
he's just standing there.
I felt so bad.
I feel so bad for him.
Like, what we put him through by accident.
Yeah.
We just forgot.
And the moment we duck our
heads back into the door,
Jenna's like, "The
proposal! Get back out!".
So we, like, turn around
before everybody disperses.
It was like that quick.
No one started moving yet.
But then you started
talking into the microphone,
which had been cut off.
And the microphone was off.
The music was playing.
People are dispersing.
Now we're yelling,
"Don't leave! Don't leave!"
"Please don't leave!"
And that's like, so we ended
up handing it over to him.
I did say at that moment,
do not let this be indicative
of how MythiCon's gonna go.
Because, thankfully, we're actually
not in charge of the details.
Like, this is one of the things
that we were supposed to remember,
but our team is better at
remembering those kinds of details.
I don't want to dog anybody,
but it kinda was indicative of MythiCon,
we'll get into that in a few ways,
that like some things
don't go exactly as planned
and you have to roll with
it and make the best of it.
But back to what I was saying
when I was giving the speech,
what I told them there, that
I was saying again here,
is that like we hatched MythiCon
in the throes of the pandemic.
We missed that interaction with fans.
You know, we had two years
of on and off touring
and we were like, let's do an event.
Let's make something that is an experience
and we need to make it something
that is not just called a convention.
And it's not just where people show up
to see us do a show alone
or just watch people record their podcast.
Like, I just was kind of,
we were immediately
averse to just creating
what we had already
experienced at VidCon honestly,
but only for Mythical Beasts.
We wanted to do something
that was a holistic experience
and we thought the venue would
have a lot to do with that.
And it turns out we were
taking a lot of risks
when we picked a venue that was outdoors
and a lot of those things.
But, like, we did it
because it was so charming
and unlike any other place you could go.
And once you showed up there, I mean,
it was kind of like being at
a very preliminary version of Disney,
if it was just us, you know,
like, on like a small primordial scale.
But that was kind of the idea.
So when fans, actually a
couple of fans were like,
this is kind of like a Disney experience.
Because the team tried to think of
all the details along the way
and you know, if you read
the fine print on things,
you would see that there
were jokes on them.
You know, that's kind of
an example of, you know,
yes this sign says 'do not
enter this particular building',
but then it also makes a joke about that.
I can't remember the jokes.
A lot of them had to do with
you not being allowed in the building.
Right.
Which I found very funny.
Yes, yes to that.
And I think that, incidentally,
most of the challenges and lessons learned
are related to the fact
that we chose such a specific
venue that was isolated,
that required shuttling people to it.
That all your food options and everything,
you're there, right?
You're kind of isolated on this island.
We made a decision,
because we were going for
this more memorable, unique experience
that created challenges that obviously,
and we knew this going in,
but challenges that you wouldn't have
if you were at a convention
center where you've got-
Hotel rooms.
A convention center
is designed to have a convention at it.
And transportation to a convention center,
a lot of times is just
walking from your hotel room,
which is somewhere.
If you want other
options for things to do,
you can just step right out
and go to things in a metro
area, that kind of thing.
So we understand that those are things
that created challenges,
but a convention center
is a convention center.
I'm not saying that if we,
you know, do this again,
it won't be at a place
that can accommodate
those kinds of things.
Which I guess, this is
a good time to go ahead
and talk about the fact that
we were planning on this
even before MythiCon,
just so you know.
We had made a decision in the months
leading up to MythiCon 2022,
that we were not going
to do a MythiCon 2023,
because we wanted more than 12 months
in order to learn the
lessons that we learned in 22
and be able to apply them in 23.
Because there's things
like selecting a location,
taking into account the amount
of the work that our team did
and how do you divide that
between the Mythical team.
And then we worked with, on location,
a great company that does festivals.
So, in order to give ourselves more runway
for lessons learned and
planning and moving forward,
we're just gonna go ahead and tell you
that there's not a MythiCon 23.
We already knew that going in,
but it's worth mentioning now
as we're talking about this.
Again, because if we do it
again or when we do this again,
we want it to be done even better
and be a step up from where we started.
Yeah.
So at this point, kind of,
everything's on the table
in terms of, like, how we
follow up MythiCon 2022
with something that, the earliest
it would be would be 2024.
Right.
In terms of how we do it.
But I would, I just really,
I just consider the whole thing a success.
You know, I know that, you know,
it wasn't about the money, you know,
I'll also be honest about that.
You know, we, you know,
we didn't make money.
I'm just, you know, I think we broke even.
I don't think we broke even.
Oh, okay.
Well, I'm gonna think that
because it makes me feel...
We're still working through,
we're still working through the finances,
but as of right now,
all indications are that
we paid to make MythiCon happen.
Which again...
I'm over here fixing my hair
because I don't want to hear.
Well, no, but again...
It was worth it.
It was totally worth it.
But also it wasn't a surprise.
Every single festival
that I've ever heard of
cost the people who
threw the festival money
the first time they did it.
We went in saying,
"Listen, this is not gonna
be a money making venture.
Maybe one day it will
be, but this is not".
And people are probably thinking,
"Man, for the money I paid for my ticket".
Yeah.
"You still didn't make any money".
But, like, yeah, like,
that's all part of it.
There were lots of comments going around
about another money grab
by Mythical, which again,
it's not the kind of thing
we're gonna come out and say,
"Guys listen, we are paying to do this".
But that is the fact.
Yeah.
Is that it was not a money grab.
There's lots of ways that
we could do a money grab,
if we chose to.
But it was starting,
it was beginning something,
just like in the book of Mythicality
when we talk about pick
a direction and go,
just start doing something.
We have a tendency, and listen,
we do a lot of things that don't work
because we do a lot of things.
And if you do a lot of things,
you're gonna do a lot of
things that don't work.
And we knew going into this that
it's very unlikely unless
we score like, again,
because, like, the, you know,
we called Liquid Death a sponsor.
They were a sponsor in that
they gave us the water.
Which was huge.
We didn't get any money.
We would have to get a number of sponsors
the festival world where we learned,
is an interesting thing
and so now that we've done it
and it was a positive experience
for the majority of people who were there,
next time maybe you can begin to introduce
those kinds of things that
help support it financially
in a way that it becomes
a money making venture.
Which again, we would want it to be,
because we don't want to
pay out of our own pockets
and lose money every time
we do something like this,
regardless of how special it was.
But totally, totally fine for that
to be the case in the first one.
Yes.
And just take a quick aside
here, speaking of things
that we're not charging
Mythical Beasts for,
but that are amazing and
edifying experiences,
I want to invite you to
go over to sporked.com.
It's the website that we created
where all of our taste tests
of anything you can buy
in the grocery store
are reflected in ranking
form and in articles.
And if there's, like, new types of snacks
or grocery store items that you can try,
our team has tried it at Sporked
and they're writing about it,
so you can be exposed to
what's the best thing to buy
and what's the new fun things to buy.
Go to sporked.com.
You don't have to pay a dime.
Oh, you just came up with a little jingle.
It's free.
I never got back to talking about
how I was feeling in the days approaching.
Yeah, get back to that.
But I gotta say, with
every year that passes,
I feel like both of us get better
at just dealing with
increasing amounts of pressure
to perform or for
something to be pulled off.
And eventually you just get to this point
where you're like, there's, I mean,
I'm doing everything I can
to make this everything that it can be
and everything that we want it to be.
But there's a number of things
that are outside of our control.
And just, you know, the
larger that Mythical gets
and the more things that we try,
the more kind of impervious you get
to just stepping into another experience
that you feel completely unqualified for.
I feel like every single year,
I'm just doing something else
that I feel unqualified for.
My life has almost become
doing things that I feel unqualified for.
And so I've actually gotten better.
Oh yeah.
At not being nervous about things.
Definitely.
But there was a lot of,
I think, hidden stress
that was popping up in certain
ways that I wasn't, you know,
I was trying to talk
about them in therapy.
There were things like,
and I know this is the
case for both of us,
in addition to MythiCon
and everything else
that we continually have
going on, just, you know,
running Mythical and everything
else that we're doing.
There was these special
sort of inaugural events,
in their own right, of me
performing as James and the Shame
and you making your DJ debut
and doing the dance party.
Kind of what we were calling
the bookends of MythiCon,
of me kind of opening
things up on night one
and you closing things down on night two.
That I was very nervous
about because, you know,
while I have performed music
in front of crowds for years,
I've never done music like that.
And I was performing my whole album,
which I had never
performed live for anyone.
And Jessie was joining me
and Jessie was super nervous
because she hasn't been
in front of an audience
in a very long time.
Right.
It was the new thing that
took a lot of your focus,
you know, because it was,
that was a big deal, you know,
and you hadn't done it before.
Yeah, I definitely felt
that way about the DJ set.
You know what, I have so much
that I want to talk about,
about my DJ premiere and some
things that happened afterward
that I haven't told you about.
Like, there's so much, people are asking,
how did I come up with the name.
And, like, the entire
experience was so surreal.
Like the costume, everything
that went into it,
went into the persona.
I'd love to just table that
until, like, next episode.
Because I have so much
that I want to unpack
and tell you about.
We can just have a ElkHound
SnuggleBaby unpacking
Episode.
Yeah, that sounds like a plan.
I have so much and I want,
there's so much I want to hear from you
that I haven't asked you about.
Like your vantage point
of the whole thing.
Oh, I had quite a vantage point.
So next episode, we'll talk about the
ElkHound SnuggleBaby of it all.
But yeah, I was talking to Jessie about,
I was like, "You know what,
I can help you be less nervous
because, like, you're
kind of doing something
that I have a point of
reference for, you know.
In terms of, like, singing with Rhett,
showing up for sound check,
performing songs that you rarely perform".
And then we didn't get to talk
until we were, like, on the
way to the airport together.
And she's like,
"Where is all this advice
you're gonna give me?".
And I thought I had
some really good advice.
I was like, "First of all,
you're gonna be nervous".
Like, I don't get nervous
about a lot of things,
the point you were making earlier,
because you just have
to do something a lot
to get to a point where
you're not nervous about it.
Like, to do something big,
that you've never done
before, in front of a crowd,
or maybe for you listening,
you're taking your own risk.
It might not be crowd oriented,
but it's something that you're, like,
putting yourself out there.
You're going out of your comfort zone.
Absolutely, you're gonna be nervous.
And that's gonna keep happening
until you do it so much
that you actually start,
you need to look for something
else to make you nervous.
That's a great thing about
James and the Shame for you
and the DJ set for me and MythiCon was,
a lot of my emotional energy
was geared towards those things
because they were so new.
So I just, you know, I was like,
"Yes, you're gonna feel nervous.
It's totally, it's part
of this, it's part of it.
Trying to find a way to
have some fun in the moment,
is kind like a north
star. It may not happen".
But I was like,
"The only practical advice I can give you
is when you're singing,
when you go up there and
you sing for the soundcheck,
don't worry about what any
crew or anybody thinks.
Like, you're not trying
to sound good for anybody.
So don't even worry about that".
I used to be fixated on that.
Like, let's write a song
called the Soundcheck song
so that we can not seem so
stupid out there for soundcheck.
That's how self-conscious I
used to be about soundchecks.
I was like, "Don't worry about that.
This is about you getting comfortable.
And for me, when I sing with Rhett,
and I'm on a mic and in a place
that I don't know what it sounds like,
I sing the melody, I sing in unison
before I break into any harmony,
just so I can tell".
And then I was like,
"I thought this was, like,
gonna be the best advice ever".
And she's like, "Yeah,
that's not gonna work for me.
Like that would totally mess me up.
I would totally lose my harmony line".
Well, because like me,
because she is not a
typical harmony singer,
she has a tendency to
begin singing the melody.
The way that she screws up
is by singing the melody by accident.
Well, that's a lot worse than going flat.
Anyway.
So that was a big moment.
So just to go to that, I mean,
that was the first night,
we did the welcome.
I think there's a lot of
things packed up in this
that kind of speak to MythiCon broadly.
Yeah.
So the first thing we did
when we got there on Thursday,
so we arrived on Wednesday night,
but then Thursday mid-morning
we show up at Star Hill Ranch,
is where we had it.
And what we knew was
that, rain, first of all,
it had rained on Monday
pretty significantly
and it was supposed to
rain on Friday morning.
So, everybody's arriving
at 3:00pm on Friday.
The first, now Paisley.
Nothing's paved here.
It's a ranch.
Well, yeah.
Everything's dirt.
There's gravel and there's dirt.
But so Paisley kind of gives us the tour
of the stuff that had already been set up.
There's still a lot of things
that were coming together,
you know, on that day,
because people are getting
there, setting everything up,
but kind of takes us through,
these are all these little,
there's basically houses
and structures, buildings
all along this thoroughfare.
And each one had been
themed in a certain way.
It was, you know, here's
the Mythical movie house
where they're constantly
running, you know, sets.
Different programming about...
Yeah, there's the Mythical Museum.
Which was awesome!
Which was super cool.
The attention to detail
for that was awesome.
Kind of baked into the
meet and greet hall.
There's the merchandise
area, there's the saloon.
The VR experience.
There's a VR experience,
there's the Cotton Candy Randy House.
Where you can, like, see
an accurate representation
of the entire GMM set
and pick up everything
and, like, hear us talking
in your ear about everything
that you're interacting with
and darts that you're throwing.
Yeah.
So we took a tour of all that,
getting increasingly excited.
Then we go down to the main stage.
There's a barber shop!
There's a barbershop, tattoo parlor.
People were getting their hair cut,
their head shaved, their beard trimmed.
Well, okay, there was a tattoo parlor
and we did not anticipate
the literal several
people who wanted tattoos.
Waiting for hours.
So we actually had to...
To get an appointment.
People got turned away because,
it's one of those things that,
we had it in mind from the beginning.
We want to offer people tattoos,
we want people to get tattoos at MythiCon.
And we were like...
Everybody wanted one, apparently.
What percentage of like 2,300 people
would want to get tattoos, right?
Apparently 50%.
More than you would think.
So anyway, so we're
getting excited about it,
but then we go down to
the main stage area,
which is an amphitheater,
sort of, you know,
outdoor amphitheater, sort of grassy area.
But the first thing we kind of notice
is that there's a lot of
mud amongst this grass.
I don't know the logistical history
of exactly how we got to this point,
but we were kind of alarmed
and they were bringing in,
like, gravel, like, you know,
crushed granite and stuff
and there were like trucks coming in
and the guy who owns the place is, like,
in a, you know...
Bobcat.
A bobcat, like, moving stuff around.
And we're like, okay, this
is a little disconcerting.
They're like, "It's gonna rain on Friday,
we're gonna cover the
whole thing with plastic,
baseball field style".
But getting a little nervous about that
because that was where
three very important things
were happening the first night,
James and the Shame performance,
the live Ear Biscuit
that we were gonna do on Saturday morning,
and then of course the main
stage show on Saturday night.
And for each thing
there was like a separate
stage presentation
that we had prepared.
Right.
So that we weren't stealing
the thunder from our, like,
main performance on Saturday night.
And it allowed everybody to
sit down in the amphitheater
and, like, lounge.
And it was kind of, like,
our vision was like picnic style hangout,
a lot of space, and even
monitors setup I think.
So it was like, it went from that to like,
"Okay, we're just trying
to keep this thing
as dry as possible".
And there's no, we were like,
"There ain't no way it's gonna happen".
You know, I'm a civil engineer by degree
and at least by training
for a couple years.
And drainage.
Drainage and grading
and sort of, you know,
pervious, you know, permeable surfaces.
That was my specialty.
So this is your fault.
So, I actually, the
first thing I said was,
"This is not, I don't
feel great about this.
I don't feel great about
this being okay by Friday".
The first thing I said when
I showed up on Thursday.
But you weren't wearing a hard hat.
So no one listened to you.
Hard hat!
So I, and this is really what represents,
we talked about this on stage at the show
and also at the James and the Shame show.
This sort of captured, our
rehearsal on Thursday night,
I think is a perfect
encapsulation of what Mythical is.
And what Mythicality is
from a creative perspective.
Because Jessie and I get up there
to sing these songs
for the first time live
and also for the first time
on an amplified system.
Which, you know, there's
a difference between
sitting down in your living room
like Jessie and I have been practicing
these songs in our living room.
It's strange.
That's what I was trying to tell her.
And we were hoping that we would have time
to maybe play a show somewhere in LA
on, like, an amplified system.
Of course we don't have time for that.
So the day approaches,
it's like, here we go.
So the first thing I
noticed as I started singing
into this giant sound system
that's being broadcast
through the whole place
is that I sound horrible.
That's the first thing you think
because your ear has to tune into the way
that everything is happening
and the monitors and the PA.
You practiced.
You did that rehearsal
The whole album.
For an hour.
I played the whole album
and I played the songs,
Jessie performed on three songs,
we played those songs at least
Multiple times.
three times each.
Until the point where I'm
like, "Okay, I feel good".
So Jessie leaves.
And then you walk out of
a building and come down
and without, like, changing
clothes or anything,
we immediately go into the
main stage show rehearsal.
And at that point is when
you can kind of see, like,
these confused looks on people's faces.
Because here I'm up there playing these
serious country songs about
religious deconstruction,
which is so out of the blue
and then all of a sudden.
And all the crew and
people who are just hired
to make everything happen.
They don't know what they're there for.
They're just like, okay,
I can understand this.
Then the next thing you know
He's a country artist?
Another guy shows up
and we're suddenly riding
on a double bicycle,
rehearsing our route up onto stage.
Right.
At which point we rap,
♪ Everything's okay ♪
♪ Cause I'm on vacation ♪
And at that point you
see people leaning over
and talking to each other and actually,
after that rehearsal that
night, I walked past a guy
and he was trying to
explain what was going on
and I heard little bits and pieces like,
"They do YouTube and they've got fans
that are showing up here".
Yeah.
And so, the fact that...
Other than that I can't help you.
And then if they stuck around
for the ElkHound SnuggleBaby reveal,
it's just the same guy that you saw,
now in this outfit doing this.
Yeah.
But the thing I told the crowd
at the James and the Shame show,
and maybe at the main show,
that's the beauty of Mythicality.
That's the beauty of Mythical.
We're well rounded individuals,
you never know what you're gonna get.
Because, to everyone who was there,
it makes complete sense
that there's this guy and his wife
singing these serious
country songs and then...
That are making people weep.
Yeah, and listen, I'll tell you about
how I got through that set
without crying in a moment.
But then, he and this other
guy are doing this crazy show
where they summon an alien
and we'll get into that.
And then it follows up with the other guy,
who joined him on stage,
is now in this outfit
that I'll let you describe
at a later point.
Thank you.
He calls himself ElkHound SnuggleBaby
and he's DJing a party.
To any outsider, it makes no sense at all.
But to a Mythical Beast, it's like,
"Yeah, of course, this
completely makes sense.
It all fits together in this world".
I loved it.
And I love the fact...
I love it so much.
that those people get it.
And that's why we did it,
because they do get it.
And that's what I told Jessie, I said,
"The reason you shouldn't be nervous
is because this audience
will be the warmest audience
and most supportive audience that
you could possibly imagine".
Oh yeah.
So much so, that when she comes out,
they go nuts when she comes out.
And she was trying not to cry.
She was, you could see it.
She was like trying not to cry.
And I was like, I was thinking,
"I told you, I told you you
had nothing to worry about".
Now it's impossible to tell
somebody to not be nervous.
And she started singing and she was like
No, she sounded great.
Let me tell you man.
So that was, just to
talk briefly about that
and we can move on.
Well, there was just the
one part of the story
you can't leave out,
is that we're driving to
the venue Friday morning
to then, like, get ready
for the whole thing.
Yeah.
And we get a phone call
from Stevie who's like,
"I'm already here. We're moving.
Nothing is on the amphitheater stage.
Nothing except for your main show.
No Ear Biscuits, no James
and the Shame tonight".
"We're moving it all to the big tents".
Because we have to do everything we can
to try to preserve the grounds
so that people can see
your main show there.
So all of that practice
you did and acclimation,
you got to that sound system.
Forget all of that.
Because now James and the Shame
is performing in the big tent.
And the big tent,
the reason James and the
Shame and Ear Biscuits
were not originally
scheduled for the big tent,
is because they're not big
enough for the amount of people
that we anticipated being
at those two events.
Right.
So...
We made the best of it.
Everybody had to stand.
That wasn't ideal.
It wasn't ideal.
From my perspective...
But you know,
everybody made the best of it.
From my perspective,
I didn't let it affect me.
Because I was like,
"Of course, of course
I'm gonna have to..."
You can't let it affect you.
I spent all that time getting ready
on this particular sound system
and now we've gotta go do a sound check,
a short sound check, on
this completely new system
and just be ready for it.
So Jessie and I show up, we do
our sound check in the tent,
you know, completely different sound.
It feels completely different
but readjusted pretty quickly.
And so I was like, okay.
And I was like, "I hate the
fact that people are going to,
there's gonna be people who can't see
because there's only so many
people that can fit in here
and we've got these TVs"
and we did what we could in a very-
Shout out to the Mythical team.
And also Gary and Matt who, you know,
produced the show from
an acoustic standpoint
and beyond that, you know,
basically just made the technical aspects
of the live events happen.
Very quick adjustments.
But that was unfortunate because
people did have to stand
and some people couldn't see
and it just wasn't planned,
it wasn't how wanted to,
it was inaudible.
The energy was great though
because everybody was so jammed in there.
And, like, at the beginning of your set,
from my perspective, I was like, you know,
we kinda had to hide.
Like, I was literally looking
through a crack in the tent
watching your set.
And then later on, they
found a space for us
to go up to the front, like,
be right next to the stage,
which ended up working out.
But, like, even from that vantage point
of like looking through a crack,
it was just, it was electric.
The heat, the body heat and smells
that were coming out of that tent.
I was like, man, everybody's excited.
Well, especially at the final party.
Oh God.
We can talk about that next time.
So it was a wonderful experience.
I mean, I said it on Twitter the next day.
One of the most special nights of my life.
I completely believe that,
the whole thing was special.
That performance because it was
being able to sing these
songs to a group of people
who, you know, I didn't know.
You never know, like,
how many of these people
who are Mythical Beasts
are listening to the songs.
I don't know.
But when I start singing
and they immediately start singing along.
That's awesome.
And so I was closing my eyes for
pretty much the whole time.
You may have noticed if
you watched me perform.
For two reasons, number one,
because I was trying
to remember the lyrics.
Because when you haven't
performed these songs live,
it's another part of your
brain that you have to turn on
in order to remember 11 songs in a row.
Yeah.
Chords and lyrics.
And also try to stay on tune.
And also trying not to cry.
Because I was like,
"If I really take in
what's happening right now
and the way that these
people are being supportive"
and God knows if I look at
anybody on the front row,
every time I kind of peeked
down there, people are weeping.
I'm like, so if I did open
my eyes, I looked above them,
like my dad taught me to
do in public speaking.
You gotta look above the crowd,
so you don't get distracted.
Just the feedback from people
in all of our meet and greets.
By this point, we had already done
one, two hour meet and greet.
Right before, yeah.
That was before our welcome.
So it was kind of cool to, like,
because we couldn't walk around.
It was kind of cool to
have that meet and greet
and to hear from fans and
their first reactions.
But then the second meet and
greet, on the second day,
is when people were able to talk to you
about the James and the Shame experience.
And people just had so many
heartwarming, moving things to say
about our deconstruction stories,
their identification with it,
even if they ended up
in a different place.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They were grateful for it.
And then the people who
connected so much with the music,
it's like, your album has
become this, in their own words,
like a lifeline.
A lifeline, like, something
they can hold onto
that's, like, they have this
shared experience in music
that, like, a lot of
couples were talking about
how they connect over this album
because it, a lot of
people were saying how,
it expressed the things that
they couldn't put into words,
much less music.
And I was really moved to just, you know,
just to witness everybody come up
and say how much they connected with that.
Obviously, it was happening
during the concert,
but, like, the stuff
they had to say after...
It was very moving.
So special.
And it was so special for Jessie too.
I mean, first of all,
we almost didn't perform 'Kill a Man'
because it's so guitar driven
and I didn't wanna sell it short
by just doing an acoustic version,
but we put an acoustic version together.
I'm so glad we did it
because it was the
highlight of the concert.
Because Jessie, you know,
which a lot of people didn't know,
that she's the one singing the opera
on that part of 'Kill a Man'.
Yeah.
And she did it and...
Jaw's were dropping.
She brought the house down.
Yeah, it was crazy.
The length of applause
when she was done with it,
I was like, "I don't know how
long this is gonna go on".
Oh yeah.
It blew people's minds.
She felt so good.
It was such a good experience
for her so much so,
you know, where she was like,
"Okay, I feel like if we
have to do that again,
I can think about it in a way
that actually I can anticipate
it in a positive way".
I will take this,
just to quickly move on
from James and the Shame,
I did wanna say, because I
don't wanna forget about it.
I announced it at MythiCon,
and I'm gonna announce it right here,
that a lot of people asked
about having a physical album
for 'Human Overboard'.
And so, that is on sale right now.
We're gonna have, sort
of, a pre-sale window.
I'm selling a record and yes,
also a CD and a cassette,
because people, we were
selling smaller quantities
of the CD and the cassette,
but there was was enough
people who asked about it.
So it's a pre-order.
You gotta like, say,
you gotta make an order
and then that way you
know how many to make.
Yeah, and you know,
you're gonna have to
be patient, obviously,
because vinyl production
is very slow right now,
but there's a pre-order window.
We've got a really cool design.
We're kind of taking, being
inspired by the album art
to actually make a record that has this
cool, like, color splash.
You know, we're not just
doing a black record.
It's this blue and green, sort
of, tie dye color mix thing
that's happening on the record.
Really nice interior sleeve with lyrics.
And then the CD's probably
gonna have this, like,
poster fold inside, it's got lyrics on it
and that kind of thing.
And also there's some
exclusive merch that's being,
you can bundle with it, or you can get it,
just kind of as part of the
'Human Overboard' physical album.
Got a t-shirt that has, like,
a cool bluegreen, kind of, tie dye pattern
that's coming off of like
the ocean inspiration
from the album cover and even a sweatshirt
with lyrics from 'Give A Damn' on it.
So, you can bundle that together,
you can get them individually.
Again, jamesandtheshame.com.
This stuff's not gonna
be available for long.
And also the first few
hundred or so copies
of the record that I sell,
I'm gonna have a signed exclusive postcard
that goes inside those,
so it comes with a signature as well.
So jamesandtheshame.com,
appreciate your support.
You know, we were well taken
care of in terms of planning,
you know, even when it
comes to like security,
that was a big unknown.
When you hire an event production company
to work on something,
they don't know our fans
and it's like, okay,
as part of this you gotta
have security detail.
You gotta make sure that,
you know, for any event,
you want everybody attending to feel safe.
And then also as, like,
talent on this thing,
they wanted us to feel safe.
So, like, there was security
that were assigned to
different things, including us.
And, you know what I'll say,
the Mythical Beasts
were, like, super chill.
It was like, it felt in a lot of ways like
a family reunion, you know,
it's just like some
people wanted pictures,
a lot of people just wanted
to give a friendly hello,
you know, if they happened to see crew,
the crew had great experience
in interacting with fans.
And so, you know, credit
to Mythical Beasts
and how grounded they were.
So many people came up.
And we've heard this before
when we do, when we tour,
people, the venues are like,
"How are your fans so cooperative?
And they don't cause trouble
and they're not rowdy
and they're not rude".
That was what everybody
at Star Hill was saying.
Yeah.
They were talking about, they were like,
"They don't litter".
And then when somebody, like,
they were telling a story,
there was a time when
somebody took a trash can,
a trash bag out of a trash
can, in order to throw it away.
And there's that moment
where you don't have a trash bag in there.
Yeah.
And, like, one of the
fans came up to somebody
who worked there and said,
"We need to get a bag in
here so people, you know".
I love that.
They didn't have their own bag.
That's the community.
I would have had my own bag.
That's the community that
we together have cultivated,
is a group of good people.
But.
I love it.
I will, I do have to share this one story.
I mean, there's an exception to every rule
and I didn't tell you ahead of time,
but I'm just gonna share
it, it doesn't matter.
So, the security that we had, they were,
yeah, they were taking care of us.
So, you know, I felt safe,
but like Christie told
me at a certain point
that, like, as she was,
I think it was the James
and the Shame concert,
because they got a place,
they were ushered to a place, like,
Christie and the kids,
behind the sound area.
And then there was somebody
who was making her pretty uncomfortable
because they just kept staring at her.
And, like, and then she
would look over her shoulder
and this guy was staring at her
and then she started looking more often.
And I was like,
"Well he probably thought
you were interested".
She was like, "Every time I
looked back he was closer".
And she said he had like shifty eyes,
kinda like, looking at
her and looking around.
So then she called...
Didn't seem to be enjoying himself.
Uhuh. And then so she, but
she did the right thing
and she got someone to contact security
and reported this guy and said,
"Okay, there's somebody here
who's making me really uncomfortable.
He's staring at me, he's not
happy, he's getting closer".
And the security said,
"We'll get right on it".
And then the guy who was staring at her
turned out to be the head of security.
Yeah, this is such a Christie story.
It's like, we're gonna call
the head of security right now.
And then all of a sudden the person
that's staring at Christie's
answering the phone
like, "Yeah, I got you".
You know what, I wonder how that was,
it was just like, "Could
you describe him?".
"He's got on a black jacket".
"He's got an earpiece in".
"He's bearded with gray hair, khakis".
She turned in the head
of security to security.
"He's currently talking on the phone"
Yeah, and they were great.
I mean, I'm like clueless.
I'm like, "Oh yeah, like
there's eight security".
And again, not that the Mythical Beasts
are to be worried about,
but again, it's standard protocol.
You gotta make sure that,
that everybody from Mythical
and everybody in our family is protected
from somebody who might
want to do something.
So I think that...
And we didn't get to...
They were great.
Yeah, they were great.
We didn't get to see everything,
like all the stuff that,
all the other podcasts that went on,
like we could hear it from the stage.
And then, like, the
Mythical Kitchen, like,
baby food eating contest.
I saw Josh in a diaper beforehand
and I saw that he still
had his belt afterward.
But we didn't get to
see a lot of that stuff.
He defended his title.
But everything that we
did get to experience
vicariously through fans
and as they talked to us
in the meet and greets
or the stuff that we would
see every now and again
and all the stuff that we participated in,
it was still a very
fulfilling experience for us.
Like getting up there the next day,
my dad and I did a live dispatches
and I was just, just
grinning from ear to ear
watching him take in
all this fan adulation
for the first time.
It was so special.
Like, just watching his
experience the whole time.
It was like bringing
your kid to Disneyland
for the first time
and everybody knew your kid at Disneyland.
It's like, that's what it felt like.
But it goes a step beyond that
because it's as if your
dad has been preparing
for this moment his entire life.
He didn't seem nervous.
And it's not just that
he doesn't seem nervous.
And, you know, because people...
He was like "Finally!".
People in entertainment get their
parents involved for different reasons
because your parents
tend to be entertaining,
not necessarily as
entertaining as your dad.
But he's not just this
willing participant.
He's more than that.
He's eager.
He's loving every minute of it.
And the other thing that he's done,
which he did multiple times,
but especially at the end
when we were with the
crew after the brunch
and the crew, basically,
this was, like, us
signing off of MythiCon.
Yeah.
And it's just the Mythical crew
who had worked MythiCon,
kind of, together in a room.
He did this several times,
but he did it there as well.
He's like, this is my
opportunity to say something.
Yeah.
And so he gets everybody's attention
and he says this really sweet thing
about how welcome he feels.
And I looked at Nancy
and Nancy's tearing up as he's talking.
I know!
Nancy, his wife, your
stepmother is what she is.
I know you don't...
Yeah, technically.
Consider her that,
but that's what she is.
Technically, yeah.
They just had the best time.
It was so sweet.
And they kept talking about the fans,
the people that they were meeting.
Because you have an idea, as a parent,
you have an idea of what
it is that your child does,
but not really.
Not really.
Right.
And you can talk about it.
You can be like, yeah.
It's like, there are these people
who have identified with the things that
we and our company have
put out into the world
and they really identify with it.
To the point that they call
themselves Mythical Beasts
and they will come to an event like this.
But until you see it
and you interact with these folks,
you don't really appreciate it.
I think it was dawning on
him repeatedly that this is,
I didn't understand the
level of just commitment
and the nature of the experience.
That was cool to see.
And, of course, you know,
we gave him a special role.
Arguably the highlight.
Let's talk about,
let's talk about the main show.
So the main show,
I'm glad we were able to stream it
and then we were able
to do video on demand.
You know, it's no longer available but,
like, there were opportunities for people
to experience it who weren't there.
And I'm so glad because it
was the most fun I've ever had
on a stage of ours, I think.
I think it was our most
fun show we've ever done.
Oh yeah.
Like, from a personal
standpoint, my experience, like,
everything that we've learned
in our couple of years of touring
and doing, like, three
different stage shows.
We've done, like, very technical,
like, polished presentation.
And then with our last,
and then we did a Bleak Creek thing,
which was like more intimate
and totally different.
But then like the Rhett & Link tour,
where it was just like music and banter
is where we really started to learn
that the looser, the better, you know.
A lot of what we're
learning just with, like,
Good Mythical Morning and
Good Mythical more in general,
is that putting ourselves in environments
where we can be ourselves
and interact with each other
and interact with people is
where we do our best work.
Right.
And just surprise each other.
And it's not about hitting
marks or certain lines.
However, that all being said,
there were from some very
important marks to be hit.
Yeah.
You know, because the show
consisted of, I think,
five musical performances from
everything from, you know,
starting out by coming
in on the double bike
and doing the 'I'm on Vacation',
to a few acoustic performances,
to closing it out with a
black light, glow in the dark
recreation of our 'So Dang Dark' video,
that was super fun to put together.
Intermingled or intermixed with
something we've never done before,
which is bringing a segment
of GMM live on stage
in the international dart game.
When we sang the
"Where in the world do these
Mythical Beasts come from?",
and then the doors open
and Chase the cartographer
came out with that map, like,
five times as big as the normal map.
They went crazy for Chase.
Oh yeah.
Like, I was so happy for Chase
that, like, he had such
a moment, you know?
Oh yeah.
It was wonderful.
And then of course...
And Stevie was on the mic.
Yeah, so we'll talk about the alien part,
but my point was is that
there were a lot of marks to hit
and there were a lot of
technical things to do correctly.
Yeah.
That, you know, when we did
our tour Mythicality show
a few years ago,
there was a two week rehearsal
where we like rented out a
rehearsal space in Burbank,
and we, like, literally two weeks
of going there on and off
over the course of two weeks,
getting all the marks down,
so you can take this show
and take it on the road.
This was two hours of a
rehearsal on Thursday night
to be ready for this show.
Now, we knew what we were gonna do
and we had scripted it out.
The parts that were, you know, outlined,
it's not scripted, but, you know,
when your dad showed up at MythiCon,
he didn't know he was gonna be an alien.
No, I didn't tell him.
I was like, I'll find the
right time to tell him.
Which ended up being perfect
for reasons we'll explain.
Which was at dinner
in front of everybody.
But what we knew we wanted to do was,
of course, we had this idea.
And he didn't bat an eye.
Oh no. And I didn't think he would,
but, like, now knowing
the way he interacts
with these ideas,
it's like we could get him to do anything.
Oh yeah.
But we knew...
Very dangerous.
Wanted to play around with this idea
that is an idea that
some people believe in.
I don't personally or
necessarily believe in it,
but this idea that you can
connect with aliens through meditation.
We were like, oh, that's a fun
sort of foil to do this set
where we can kind of do some improv music
where we're, like,
helping the alien zero in.
Now, I'll just go ahead and say,
if you were watching on the live stream
and you felt like that
segment just went on too long,
well, it wasn't primarily for you.
The show was primarily
Couldn't be at that moment.
for the people who were there, right?
Who were participating in that chant,
who were looking to the skies.
And we said, listen, this
is primarily for the people
who showed up to MythiCon,
but we're gonna offer it as a live stream.
Because if you wanna feel like
you're part of it, you can.
But I can imagine...
Especially that moment of, like, you know,
group meditation, that's not something
that people like stream on the internet
for like thousands of views.
And I'm sure people who were there
thought it was going on for a long time.
But again...
What's your hobby?
I like to watch other
people meditate live.
We were doing, again,
none of that was written.
The only thing that was pre-written
were the coordinates that Jenna had found
of the exact spot that
we were at, at Star Hill.
And they were on my shruti
box taped on my shruti box.
That's why I was reading my shruti box.
I was playing it.
Which is why, when that person,
and we both retweeted the thing,
like, leading up to MythiCon,
somebody tweeted that video
of this, like, hippie looking dude
playing this instrument
and then another dude
blowing bubbles on stage.
And I was like, this is
basically our version,
we've already planned our version of this.
We were already ready for it.
And so like, I love the
fact that somebody said
"This is gonna be Rhett and
Link in X number of years".
And I'm like, "No, this
is gonna be Rhett and Link
in X number of weeks".
Yeah, yeah, just get ready for it.
So it was so weird.
And we were like, yeah, set it up.
Like, listen, you're here,
you're up for anything.
So we just wanna take
full advantage of that.
So now we are going to contact aliens.
And then everybody was up for it.
Oh, they were so up for it.
Now...
It was so ridiculous.
When we originally
conceptualized this, it was just, hey,
we're gonna do this thing of,
we're trying to contact aliens.
Obviously, it's gonna fail,
but then it's gonna result in
Charles, an alien, showing up.
Now we wanted it to be something
where we might be able to fool some people
or give you the emotional feeling
of that you have made contact.
And so the first thing we looked into
was like a drone show.
Those are...
It's when you have, like,
if you don't know, like,
could be 20 or 30 or hundreds
of drones that are programmed.
To like make a giant face in the sky.
They did it,
if you look up 'drone show, Burning Man'.
It's awesome.
There's a giant face.
I mean, it's like the face
of God looking down at you.
So crazy.
Now, we already indicated earlier
that we did not make any money.
So we weren't about to spend the, like,
approximately $1 million
that it would've cost
in order to, if you get
one of these companies
to do the type of drone
show that they do for, like,
the NBA finals or something.
So we quickly downgraded
to one singular drone
that we rented.
And you may think, "Oh, okay".
But if you were there.
And if you were really close,
if you were like on the front row,
the stage is actually too
big for you to see it,
so you needed to be back,
kind of in the middle,
then everybody in the back.
I went back there during
the rehearsal and watched it
and I was like, "Oh gosh,
this is gonna be great".
Yeah, Ben rented a drone,
he piloted the drone.
And it had a big spotlight on it.
So it was very bright.
It was like a search and
rescue drone spotlight.
Yeah.
Well, and apparently, it
was so convincing that
when we were doing our brunch
the next morning, on Sunday morning,
we were saying like, "Hey,
what was your highlight?".
A lot of people said the show last night,
just absolutely loved it.
And then one person piped up and said,
"Do you guys know that right
when you were doing that thing
where you contacted aliens,
a plane flew over really, really low".
It freaked me out.
I thought maybe something
we had done had worked.
We were like,
Really?
You sure it wasn't a UFO
that then landed behind the stage?
Right, so the way it happened was
is that we're singing the coordinates,
chanting the coordinates, then chanting,
"We are looking to the skies for you".
At which point Ben kind of
brings the drone over the stage
and then slowly lowers
it down behind the stage.
And this is all choreographed
with this sound design
that Ben has put together,
including this really low, if you, again,
this is one of those things that, like,
why being there was so much different,
because they started
playing this very low rumble
that was shaking the entire place
as this drone is coming down, right?
Yeah.
Then when it lands, there's this,
it feels like this light comes
on from behind the stage.
And then, you know, it took a while
to kind of get things situated.
We were kind of waiting there for a while,
but eventually the doors open,
CO2 cannons, boom, light,
and then an alien with
a giant fricking head,
like an eight foot tall
alien with four arms
is standing there with
a three ring binder.
Yeah the alien comes out
and just kind of, like, shuffles forward.
He lifts his forearms with
the tablet in his left hand
and he says...
Binder.
A binder.
"Greetings earthlings".
I come in peace.
"I come in peace".
I don't think dad
changed his voice at all.
I'd say like a 10% change.
But this is where...
So great.
...your dad being your dad
really made this segment.
And I think the best way to illustrate
what it's like to work with
your dad in this context
is to talk about the rehearsal.
Which, basically, we had...
Welcome to your future.
We had a little discussion with him
and it was essentially,
"Charles, you know, the
doors are gonna open,
you're gonna come out, you're gonna say,
greetings, I come in peace.
Then we're gonna have a little discussion
with you about where do you come from,
what's your name?
And then you're going to say
that I brought you a gift,
it's the time gate.
And then this big sort
of elevator looking thing
is gonna kind of come out from the door.
And then you're gonna,
there's an instruction manual
that you're gonna read.
It's a three ring binder,
that explains basically why
you're giving us to this
and what we can do.
And it sets up the next bit".
"You don't have to memorize
how the time gate works,
you just read it off the manual".
And the first
So, during the rehearsal he walks out,
he spreads his arms and he says,
"Welcome earthlings".
As if we're all the ones that showed up.
"Welcome to this planet I just arrived at"
"That you're already on".
I was like, "Oh".
Okay, a little twist there.
I like that choice.
A little twist.
And we told him that
when we ask him what his name is,
that his name is Darrell in our language.
Well we said...
So then we asked him.
It's too difficult for you
to understand it in my language,
but it's the equivalent of Darrell.
Is what we told him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so then when we're
doing the rehearsal,
I'm like, "Well, what's your name?"
And he was like, "Charles".
Which I was like, that's perfect.
Like, didn't wanna change any of that.
So, he got it all right during
the show, unfortunately.
Because you kept telling me
to, like, to help him out,
to, like, make sure he had
the right lines, which he did.
Well that wasn't...
I think it would've been
even funnier if he didn't.
That actually wasn't...
He wasn't supposed to say
that his name was Darrell.
He was supposed to say that,
"I can't pronounce my
name in your language",
but he just said Darrell,
which ended up getting a laugh,
but the funniest part of the rehearsal
was when we said, "Did you bring a gift?".
And he holds up the binder and he's like,
"I brought this book".
And it was, the gift is the book.
We're like, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
The gift is the time gate".
And that's the instruction manual.
The book's the instruction manual.
And it seemed like it was
difficult for him to get.
To restore that information in his brain.
But he did, he did by the time
we got around to the show.
I'm just glad he didn't trip and fall.
You know, like bust his brain open
and I'm talking about
that huge alien brain
that was, like, his whole face
was in the mouth of the alien.
So funny.
I was so proud of him, he did awesome.
He loved every second of it.
Yeah.
It was great.
And then Jordan...
Was in the time gate.
Of course, the bit was
you can communicate with your past selves,
your present selves or your future selves.
And so we kind of brought in
what Jordan has really done
a good job with on GMM,
which is putting his mouth up to a hole.
And saying something hilarious.
And so he played young me and young you
and then old me and old you.
Yeah, but we each played present us.
And then whatever the other
one of us was as well.
It was fun.
It was a good ending for, I mean,
that was fun, that was a nice bit.
And then we, like, sang
'Lonely Sad Little Water Dispensing Tab',
did a little singalong.
And then we went away, we put on our suits
and we did the encore.
Did 'So Dang Dark'.
I almost stepped off of the stage.
I will say that, because during the encore
we had to go back and change.
And again these are...
That would've been bad.
There are these little things
that you work out doing a rehearsal,
even a second rehearsal,
that we just didn't, we didn't have time,
because we got there and here's the stage
and all the stuff's coming together,
this stuff has just
been built just in time.
So when we go back to
change out of our clothes
into these skin tight clothes
that have black light
reflective paint on them
that mimics exactly the way we looked
in the 'So Dang Dark' video.
There were no lights.
And so there were steps down to this area
that we were gonna change
and I kind of knew that
there were steps there
and I didn't know that there were, like,
they were kind of not that wide.
And so when I stepped down,
I stepped completely
down to the next level.
And, I mean, that could
have been catastrophic,
but it just happened.
You could have broken your hip.
I caught myself and
that was the only moment
that I felt unsure about this.
Again, nobody left on a stretcher.
Success.
Not even us.
And, you know, after that was my DJ set
to the close the thing out,
which we'll talk about next episode.
And then the next morning,
yeah, we had a brunch with, like,
people who had that ticket
and like you said,
we went around and talked to
a bunch of Mythical Beasts
as they were eating,
wedding reception style.
And also, the Mythical
crew was there for that,
our wives were there for that.
Really the first time
that Jessie and Christie
have interacted with Mythical Beasts
in that way, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
And, you know, the fact that, you know,
Lily and Lincoln and Lando were also there
was very special to me.
I know Locke couldn't
make it because he was,
you know, just getting going with school.
But Shepherd was there.
And I'm just so glad that they were there
it was a big part of it.
Like, Lily posted a picture of, like,
me getting ready for my DJ set,
when we're like hanging
out on this bed, like,
in one of the places the day before.
It's just like, you know,
these are all these, like,
great memories for me
that the moment I took that initial tour
and walked around right
when we arrived, I was like,
I'm so glad that my family's
showing up for this thing
and experiencing this because you know,
whatever we do next will be different.
You know, that's how we are.
So it'll be enough the same,
but enough different to still be exciting.
But to be the first one,
for it to be so special,
you know, special for
everybody who was there
and to have, like, our family there
to have so many of the
Mythical crew there.
And that they had good experiences.
It was, it all just, you
know, it was hot stress
and people had to work
themselves to the bone.
I acknowledge that, but like,
in my opinion it was
all worth it, you know,
from my perspective, I'm just so proud
of what everybody did to put into it
and that we got to experience it together.
It was just, yeah, it was awesome.
It was absolutely a
career highlight for me.
Oh yeah.
Yes, thank you to everybody
who was able to make it.
We know that, you know,
in the scheme of things,
it was a relatively small
percentage of Mythical Beasts.
But you know, many of you,
who are some of our most
active Mythical Beasts who,
you know, make their passion
for all things Mythical
known on the internet on a regular basis,
a lot of you were there.
People that we've met before,
previous tours and meet and greets.
And a lot of people we haven't met before.
Obviously, we couldn't do this without you
and you made it a very, very special thing
that we're gonna take
everything that we learned
and all the things that
made it really special,
made it unique, all the best parts of it
and try to find ways to
replicate that moving forward.
What that's gonna look like,
like you said, we don't know.
But we always love to start
something, learn from it,
keep moving forward and
there's nothing like
when we all get together like that.
And we say it every time we tour.
Yeah.
But it's just, it remains true
that there's nothing like
being in the same place
with a bunch of Mythical Beasts.
Especially after everything
that, like, you know,
with the pandemic of it all, you know.
Yeah.
It's really, it gave us
a renewed appreciation
for being there and having the
ability to create something,
have people show up and collaboratively
make it an experience.
Yeah.
You know, so very grateful.
I feel like we took our own advice,
we stopped, we celebrated.
We're gonna do more of that
in the next episode too.
Kind of.
Oh yeah, speaking of,
you said you wanna know my perspective.
I have a lot of thoughts about
the birth of ElkHound SnuggleBaby.
But do you have a rec today?
I do, it's just the same thing
I've already talked about,
which is the physical
album 'Human Overboard'.
Oh, just more self-promotion.
Yeah, right.
I just wanna make sure you know.
Not what recs are for, that doesn't count.
Okay.
I thought that was against the rules.
I think in this case it does.
Yeah, James...
Oh you know what?
I'm glad I talked about it
because if you go to jamesandtheshame.com
or you just go to any one
of my social media profiles
and click on the linktree there,
you can join the mailing list.
Look at you and your mailing list.
You know, hey, musicians man,
gotta have mailing lists.
I don't know why, but they do.
You can get a discount code
that you can apply to the album.
Oh.
That's something I forgot.
So that's worth mentioning.
So if you want to get,
I think we're doing a 10% discount code,
join the mailing list.
I'm not gonna send very
many emails, trust me,
because I'm not doing a whole lot
that needs emails sent.
But if so, when there is something special
that you need to know about
like a physical product
or a discount or whatever,
you can join the mailing list,
but mainly to get that discount.
Okay, I get it.
Jamesandtheshame.com
We'll holler at you next week.
Let us know what you think #EarBiscuits.
And of course, you can always respond
to anything that we've talked about,
give us your take on it,
1-888-EARPOD1 for the voicemail.
Hi, my name's Victoria.
I'm a nurse from Ontario, Canada.
And I just wanted to let you guys know
that most pills are both
swallowable and chewable,
but a large majority aren't,
especially those that
are extended release.
So if you have questions,
please speak to your pharmacist
before chewing any old random pill.
Thanks.
Hi Rhett and Link.
I went to MythiCon this year
and it was very cool to see Jenna
and all, like, the women that you guys
have on your crew and your team.
My work in production, you know,
very rarely has women on,
like, set and productions.
And I just wanted to make a
note of how rare it feels.
That's all I wanted to say.
Like, y'all are wonderful.
And you've surrounded yourself
with such wonderful people
and you seem to have, like, a
really awesome eye for that.
So love y'all.
Hi Rhett and Link, this is Jade
from Claremore, Oklahoma.
And I'm just curious how
you came up with the name
ElkHound SnuggleBaby.
Love it.
Hey Rhett and Link, this
is Mallory from Boston.
And a friend of mine actually
turned me on to you
guys during the pandemic
and I am forever grateful to that friend.
I was listening to your
episode from MythiCon,
which was A+ by the way,
and I really liked what you guys
had to say about friendships.
So I thought I'd provide a rec of my own,
since you guys are always providing
such great recs to all of us.
And it's a book called 'Big Friendship'
and it's by Aminatou Sow.
Check it out.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.